(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- All right. Welcome back, everybody.
We love shining a light on
people who use their imaginations
to open opportunities for others,
so do our friends at Pilot
Pen, makers of Frixion,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show."
And that is why we want to
introduce you to our next guest.
She has a screen printing company
that not only employs autistic people,
but gives them opportunities
to create fearlessly as well.
From The Awesome Company,
everybody, welcome Jacquie.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
So-
- Oh my gosh.
- Thank you for being here. We're so-
- What is happening?
- So excited.
- I'm so happy to be here. You're so cool.
- Ditto. I am not that cool.
You will find out.
But I hear that the inspiration
for this, everything,
is your son, right?
- Yes.
- Yeah, so what happened?
- He is older now,
and so I really think that
I am now my own inspiration.
Seriously.
- I love this.
Yeah.
- I'm an autism mom,
and I navigated that world
like a lot of other people.
And I noticed that the
autistic kids had a path.
It's not clear sometimes,
it's a little bumpy,
but it definitely goes into a line.
We know what resources they
need, support, friends.
But what I noticed is, you know,
autistic kids become autistic adults,
and what happens, and what
I saw happen is nothing.
And some of the individual's
lives became smaller
and opportunities were kind of bleak.
And I was like, seriously, just over it.
And so I was like, "Well,
I'm starting something.
I don't know what I'm
doing, but I don't care."
So I bought a T-shirt
printing machine and I said,
"I'm hiring people that have autism
and we're gonna print shirts for people,
and we're gonna sell 'em.
And the more T-shirts we sell,
the more autistic people I'm gonna hire.
And that's just what I'm gonna do."
So I just did it.
- And it's awesome.
(audience cheering)
It's incredible.
And that's a powerful statement,
because not everybody
knows how to do that.
I think you have the idea,
but you don't actually...
It doesn't come to fruition.
That's why I think it's incredible.
So let's talk about your employees though,
'cause I do wanna know,
you're only able to hire so many, right?
- Yeah.
- So that's kind of
one of the issues is you're
wanting to hire more,
but you found a way to
navigate around that, right?
- Yes, well, I was kind of at a crossroads
where I have a great group
of people that work for me,
and we have about 12 full-time employees.
And do I invest in them
or do I just keep bringing more people in?
No, I'm gonna invest in my team
because I want them to
feel valued, respected,
safe, important.
So they stay with me,
and I hold their hand,
and I seriously don't let go.
And the guys that you're gonna meet,
they'll confirm that
I'm obsessed with them.
Like, I want them to stay with me forever.
We do have a couple positions
that are always open for
individuals to come and try.
The interview process is the hardest part
of being an autistic adult.
You get nervous, freak out.
You don't know how to communicate.
You need a little bit more time.
So for me, I leave two spots
open for people to come in
wherever they are on the spectrum.
And they can work on skills,
they can work on a job for the summer,
because they have a
dream job that they want,
like work on their resume.
I am like a one-stop shop.
Like, just come to me.
We'll make it happen.
- Yeah.
- But...
- [Kelly] That's so
great. It's like a home.
(audience applauding)
- Like, I realized that
more people with autism,
I wanted to help more people
and I wanted to employ them,
and I couldn't figure out how to do it.
And then I realized, a lot of people
that were messaging me were
artists and graphic designers.
And I said, "Well, I
have an art background.
I used to own an art
gallery. You can do this."
And so I put out a recruitment
for autistic artists to
submit their artwork for me.
And it's all wearable art,
so you can go to our website.
You can see all the
autistic artists' work.
And I paid for all of their
designs, so they get paid,
and with every item
sold, they get royalties.
So I just printed more.
- That's incredible.
(audience applauding)
Like, that's important, right?
The important part of
it is also getting paid.
- Payment is, without a doubt,
the most important thing to me.
And the spectrum is large.
When you meet someone with autism,
you've met just one person with autism.
So there's all kinds of
people on the spectrum,
but some people need more support,
and maybe they don't quite get
that they just made 15 bucks that hour.
But maybe when they go to the store later
and they buy something like...
Sorry, they realize that they earned that.
- Yeah.
- And it's like
so important to me.
(audience applauding)
- It really is important to
feel that you have purpose.
Like, that impact, you will see
that written on their faces.
- Just valued friendship.
Someone you can count on.
But the communication, like, sure,
maybe you're not doing
the regular communication,
but everyone knows that we
all have each other's back,
and the world can be kind
of scary and ours isn't.
- Yeah. I love that.
(audience cheering)
The Awesome Company focuses
on hiring autistic employees
to screen-print T-shirts
and other items that are made to order.
We have two of those staff
members joining us now.
Everybody, give a big
hello to Brian and Matt.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
So, hello, how are y'all
doing? Thank you for coming.
- Thank you for having us.
- Yeah, thanks for having us.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- I like your shirt.
Are these shirts y'all made?
- Oh yeah, oh yeah.
They're pretty awesome.
- They're pretty awesome (chuckles).
(Matt laughs)
I know, I gotta give it...
So, Matt, I'm gonna start with you.
Like, how did you come across
this? The Awesome Company.
- So I was bouncing around from jobs,
trying to find something that stuck,
but nothing was open and
understanding of autism.
And then one day, I heard Jacquie
here was recruiting people
on the spectrum.
And so I thought, "I'll apply,"
went in and I've been there
since, for five years now.
- Oh my gosh.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
That has to change your
life. It changed my life.
First of all, you surround yourself
with people you wanna
work with on a daily,
and then also just having
a job that you enjoy
and you feel purpose.
That had to change your life,
right? What is it like now?
- It feels amazing just
waking up, going in there,
knowing that I'm gonna see
the same people every day.
And that if I'm having a
problem or a great day,
I can always talk to Jacquie
or Brian, or whoever's there.
- Yeah.
- It just made me feel happy
to know that I found a new home.
- Yeah.
(audience applauding)
- I love it.
(Jacquie laughs)
Well, Brian, now I wanna talk to you.
So what's a typical day like for you?
- Well, there is no typical
day at The Awesome Company.
One day I could be out
passing out marketing bags
to business districts,
another day I could be cutting
film to print on shirts,
another day I could be
writing thank you notes.
We write these handwritten
thank you notes.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's awesome.
- [Brian] Penmanship is key.
It really is a lost art.
- [Kelly] I know. It is.
- It really is.
- We do thank you cards here.
I do that for people here in-
- We decided-
- That's awesome too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We decided that we wanted
to connect with our community
in a world that you kind of
feel distant from people.
So every single person
that buys a T-shirt from us
or a garment custom apparel,
they receive a handwritten
note from us saying,
"Thank you so much for
letting us earn your business
and please tell your friends about us."
And it really is a great job,
but also, we're connecting
with the community
and we're getting so much good love back,
and it's just wonderful.
So you have the best penmanship, I think.
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
(audience laughing)
Oh yeah.
(audience applauding)
- Well, Matt does some design work,
and he made a special piece
that he wanted to share.
So is this-
- Oh yes.
We have a little surprise for you, so-
- Oh, it's for me.
- It's for you.
- Okay.
- Right when we found out
that we were gonna be here, I said,
"Matt, you gotta make her a drawing."
And we researched what you loved.
So we realized you liked
sunflowers.
- Cobalt blue.
- Yes.
- Cobalt blue
is her favorite.
- I love cobalt blue.
- [Jacquie] And we heard that
you might be a good singer.
- You did research.
That's a specific color.
- So, Matt made this for you.
- Oh my gosh, I love it.
- Aw.
- It's sunflower.
(audience applauding)
- But...
- With the music notes.
Oh, more?
- And...
- And to show what we do at
The Awesome Company is we put
that artwork on some
clothes for you to wear.
- Oh my gosh, thank you.
(audience applauding)
I wanna see it.
- So now you have a little bit
of The Awesome Company with you.
- Oh my God, I'm gonna open
it now. I'm so excited.
This is so awesome.
Well, awesome. I didn't mean to say that.
(Matt laughs)
- Yeah.
- That is so nice.
- You're welcome.
- Oh my gosh.
Ah, well, I have something
for all of you as well.
So our season-long partner, Pilot Pen,
wants to celebrate people
creating fearlessly
and awesomely like all of you.
So they're hooking you
up with all sorts of pens
and supplies to help empower the artist
within and behind The Awesome Company.
And also, I just believe in this so much,
and I just am so proud of everything
that is being accomplished
here, and all the purpose,
and the impact on the community
I can only imagine as well.
So I'm gonna give $5,000 just to help out.
(Jacquie screams)
(drum roll thumps)
(cymbal clangs)
(audience cheering)
I think it's so amazing.
And I heard that you're
wanting to do a gallery, right?
- So that's what I was
just gonna say is like-
- I heard about the gallery
thing too.
- The universe is, like,
exploding my soul open
right now because I thought,
we have our autistic artists
and we have the wearable art,
but I don't see any art
gallery that's dedicated
to autistic artists only,
so I'm opening one.
- Oh my gosh, this is
incredible. I heard about that.
So I'm very excited about that.
- So we are gonna use this.
We're gonna use the pens
and money to help with that.
Thank you so much.
- Oh my God. Absolutely.
Well, everybody, we need
a short break.
- Hot eyeballs.
- You're doing great.
When you're crying, it
means it matters. It's okay.